there's times where people will send me
stuff and
i got a question before i repost it
anywhere like is this real and i'll have
to like you know google the title to
make sure it's a real you know piece and
then dive deeper
into it from there it's a bit of a it's
a bit of a rabbit hole you got to get
into um
you know there's one thing that we've
all noticed if you've driven on a
highway anywhere for any length of time
there's been a car accident everybody
slows down to look at it everybody wants
to look at a train wreck right and it's
and it's like i think the media
it's why they have that um
you know distilled summary uh you know
if it bleeds it leads right so i mean
they want to manufacture drama
and you know the best way to get your
attention to capture it on something it
seems is to create a train wrecker you
know create a car crash out of something
and then you know
amplify it you know we see that today
with pretty much everything like you
can't you can't say or do anything by
the fan without offending somebody
somewhere on something from some period
of time in history it's gotten to the
point where it's almost like it's gotten
a point where it's just absurd right
well it's all emotional programming
right they want you to be emotional
because then they can manipulate you and
they want it to be fear-based so that
they get an emotional reaction on you
what does that mean with the
manipulation like what are they trying
to do they're trying to keep you scared
they're trying to keep you under control
they want to keep you scared so that
you'll go you'll capitulate and go along
with all of the different um agendas
your thoughts wear your masks get your
five jabs right and and here's a case in
point i i routinely get asked this
question which kind of cracks me up but
people are saying when when did this
cancel culture really start well if you
look back in history
it started
if you really want to give it a time
frame right after 9 11.
go think about go look back and look at
anybody who questioned the narrative
around weapons of mass destruction
around the uh the attacks that were done
in 911 and they were off the air
like that i mean look at bill maher and
i'm not a bill maher fan but bill maher
said it would be you'd have to be pretty
brave to fly an airplane into a building
gone the next day
so the the cancel culture test was after
9 11 and it's just a different brand and
a different flavor right now but it's
the same game
it's
tailoring the narrative so that people
get scared they stay scared i mean think
about it the war intended terror ended
when
2010 2012 and we still have the patriot
act we still have all these different um
control mechanisms in place
that's really the end state they're
trying to reach is to reduce your
freedoms through keeping you scared to
where you accept it and they they push
it across every single medium i mean
even music now is
laced with it
yeah it's everywhere it's in it's in
advertising uh too i mean if you listen
to the radio or you watch any
commercials i mean you'll see it pop
there too oh linkedin linkedin is just
really
it's so woke it's it's it's i know
i i you know i just try to avoid as much
stuff as i possibly can and just kind of
stick to the the absolute facts um
dissect the narratives can you talk
about that a little bit
so i i gave the homework the last time i
was on the show to to look go go watch
one or one or two episodes of the rookie
and go through each screen each one of
the scenes and dissect what what the
scene's about and you will see as you go
through each one of those scenes you'll
see the overall narrative meaning that
the racist white cop
then you'll see all of the underlying
themes and messages that go along with
that um you see um i think it's in
episode three or episode four they talk
about defunding the police and the whole
narrative is around the assumption of
public safety and they their dialogue
and their their all their lines are
around the talking points and the themes
and messages around
how that's supposed to work right and
when you when you go through each scene
that see the problem i have now is when
i watch tv that's all i see is
narratives themes and messages and
drives me crazy like i can't watch that
nonsense
um but if you're if you don't know what
you're looking at look at the scene and
then break down it's almost a curse you
can't enjoy it anymore right no i mean
it's it's bad but it's true yeah so but
if you if you break down each scene if
you break down in even in written form
break down the paragraph and look at the
overall theme and you'll you'll see very
very quickly that every single medium
that you have in front of you
is laced with
with narratives and messages that they
want you to buy into and they inundate
you with it right one of the
one of the keys to success in iraq was
number one
control the airways so push out is as as
wide and as far the talking points and
narratives that we wanted the iraqis to
sign up for and you do it consistently
over time so over time they just absorb
it
and
that's what you're seeing you're seeing
these narratives being pushed over and
over across every medium and every
spectrum they can
and you see them over and over and you
start to buy into them and if you're
emotionally charged you buy into them
and then you react right look at the
floyd rides right 10 second video
blew up the nation and that was the
intent of it right i'm waiting to see
what happens with the trial going on
right now
that looks like it's going to go the
right way but we'll see what happens on
the other side of that
got a super chatter from mike lee says
mainstream media are all hypocrites if
it was up to them kyle would be held
without a trial and publicly executed so
much more misinformation
well consider them controlled assets
don't consider them hypocrites they're
controlled assets and they're told what
to publish and what narratives to push
out
so a lot of them
um it used to be a lot of good people
stuck in a bad system and that's the
same way when you think about the
agencies there's a lot of good people
stuck in a bad system
they're being told from the very very
top
how to push that narrative and if you
think i'm kidding like i said flip
between channels and local news stations
you'll see the same stories same
narrative same language even across two
or three different channels it's their
controlled assets
yeah there was something i watched um it
was on rumble and i shared it in my
community and it's also on my email list
so if you guys here i'm going to drop
the banner on the bottom because it's on
a sequence don't don't email me and ask
me to send it to you directly just get
on the list and um
wait for it to get to you because it's
not a sequence i think it's like the
sixth email in
where's my ticker so
down there below you can get on the
email list but but there's this video
that's uploaded there and they
they do exactly what you're talking
about where they take the sound bites of
a whole bunch of news stations from a
whole bunch of different anchors and
it's identical it's like a big giant
echo chamber of them saying the exact
same thing and you can tell somebody's
telling them to regurgitate this
information um it's a very very i will
tell you rich that it's
it takes a lot of logistics to
coordinate at that level across that
wide of the spectrum yeah it's a huge
amount of infrastructure a huge amount
of coordination and a very very
stringent control system to be able to
push that out i mean if you look at just
public affairs for the army or public
affairs for the navy
it takes a gargantuan effort just to say
forward reach forward power
consistently across all the military
channels
and when you look at going across both
the news channels going across radio
going across print and then movies and
every and all the other mediums that we
have it takes a huge huge amount of
coordination and a lot of technology to
be able to do that in a synchronized
fashion and the fact that you're seeing
it that synchronized and that effective
means that they've they've invested a
lot of money in that infrastructure to
make that happen
yeah and
you know you sit there and you're paying
for your cable like you're paying a
monthly subscription for your cable
paying for your internet access to
stream it on or whatever it is that it's
being delivered through and then you're
sitting there letting them indoctrinate
you with programming or indoctrinating
you with program with commercials
i mean you're basically paying to be
paying to get brainwashed right it's
programming
you